>> Greg: AS THE GAS IN
VENEZUELA UNFOLDS, WE MUST ASK
HOW DID THIS HAPPEN.
SOCIALISM.
THE COUNTRY'S ANNUAL INFLATION
RATE IS 80000%.
I AM NO ECONOMIST, BUT I WOULD
CALL THAT A LODGE.
IN SUCH CIRCUMSTANCES, PEOPLE
ARE FACED WITH GRIM CHOICES.
EITHER EAT THEIR PETS OR MOVE TO
CUBA.
MANY MODERN-DAY SOCIALISTS WILL
SCREAM BUT NO, NO, NO, VENEZUELA
ISN'T SOCIALISM AS IT IS
SUPPOSED TO BE, WHICH IS WHAT
SOCIALISM SAID ABOUT EVERYTHING
SINGLE SOCIALIST COUNTRY SINCE
FOREVER.
VENEZUELA ISN'T SOCIALISM LIKE
CUBA AND NICARAGUA AND ZIMBABWE
ISN'T SOCIALISM AND SO ON.
TO INFINITY.
THAT'S THE KEY DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN SOCIALISM AND
CAPITALISM.
CAPITALISM DOESN'T NEED LIARS
BECAUSE IT DOESN'T HAVE TO BE
PERFECT TO WORK.
IT'S DECENTRALIZED.
ONE GLITCH ONLY GOES SO FAR BUT
SOCIALISM, ONE ERROR IN THE
WHOLE THING GOES TO HELL WHICH
IS WHY IT NEEDS FOR US TO
SURVIVE.
LIKE HUGO CHAVEZ, THE DEAD
STRONGMAN ONE EMBRACED BY
AMERICAN CELEBS SEAN PENN, DANNY
GLOVER, OLIVER STONE PRAISED THE
MAN FROM THEIR COMFORTS OF
CAPITALISM.
AS LONG AS APOLOGISTS EXIST, THE
MEDIA JUST STRONGER.
FOR THE PRESS, VENEZUELA IS THE
OPPOSITE OF COVINGTON.
COVINGTON WAS EXCITING VIRAL
VIDEO, INFLAMMATORY TAPE THEY
COULDN'T GET ENOUGH OF.
VENEZUELA IS A 12 YEAR
DEATH SPIRAL, SO EASY TO IGNORE.
WE DIDN'T.
>> VENEZUELA, THE SOCIALIST
NIGHTMARE, THEY'VE GOT NO FOOD,
NO SUPPLIES, NO TOILET PAPER.
IT'S A CRAP SHOW WITHOUT TOILET
PAPER.
THEY DON'T HAVE TOILET PAPER IN
VENEZUELA.
SOCIALISM MADE TOILET PAPER
SCARCE.
I DON'T KNOW ABOUT THAT SHIRT OR
MY OBSESSION WITH TOILET PAPER.
ANYWAY, SO NOW THE PRESS CALLS
TRUMP'S ACTIONS PROVOCATIVE BY
RECOGNIZING VENEZUELA'S
OPPOSITION LEADER.
THEY CAN GO TO HELL OR WORSE,
VENEZUELA.
APPARENTLY RUSSIA IS UPSET WITH
DONALD TRUMP.
POLITICIANS HERE ARE IN
AGREEMENT.
ARE THEY IN CAHOOTS WITH PUTIN?
>> Dana: ARE THEY COLLUDING?
>> Greg: ARE THE DEMOCRATS IN
CAHOOTS WITH PUTIN OVER
VENEZUELA?
>> Dana: YOU HAVE THE BAD BOYS
OF THE WORLD, POLLUTANT AND HIS
COHORTS.
THEY ARE THE ONES WHO ARE ALWAYS
BANDING TOGETHER AND SAY
AMERICA, YOU BETTER STAY OUT OF
IT BECAUSE THEY'RE GOOD FRIENDS
WITH HUGO CHAVEZ, NO MADURO.
MY ADVICE TO THEM IS WHY DON'T
YOU PUT -- POLICE YOUR OWN AREA
AND LEAVE THIS TO US.
I THINK THIS IS A REALLY GOOD
THING.
NOT ONLY DOES PRESIDENT TRUMP
RECOGNIZE GUAIDO AS THE ACTUAL
LEGITIMATE LEADER.
WE WILL SEE HOW IT GOES, BUT THE
OTHER THING THEY DID THAT WAS
DIPLOMATICALLY SKILLFUL AND
SMART, THEY GOT ALL THE OTHER
LEADERS IN THE REGION, THE NEW
PRESIDENT FROM BRAZIL, THE GUY
FROM CHILE.
THEY HAVE ALL SAID WE BACK TO
THIS MOVE AS WELL.
SATURDAY, SECRETARY POMPEO WILL
COME TO NEW YORK.
I DON'T KNOW IF HE PRESIDES OVER
THE EMERGENCY SESSION AT THE
U.N. BUT THAT'S WHAT THIS IS
GOING TO BE ABOUT.
IT'S ABOUT TIME.
>> Greg: MARIE, WHEN WILL YOU
CONFRONT THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY
OVER THEIR MODERN SOCIALISTS?
YOU HAVE THIS GOING ON AND AOC
AND BERNIE ARE STILL WAXING
NOSTALGIC ABOUT THIS DEADLY
IDEOLOGY.
WHAT ARE YOU GOING TO DO ABOUT
IT, MARIE?
YOU PERSONALLY.
>> Marie: I DON'T LIKE MOST OF
BERNIE SANDERS OR AOC'S POLICY
PROPOSALS.
I ALSO THINK IT'S A HUGE STRETCH
TO COMPARE THEM TO WHAT'S
HAPPENING IN VENEZUELA.
WE CAN TAKE THEM ON ON THEIR OWN
AND NOT SAY THEY WANT US TO BE
VENEZUELA.
WHEN IT COMES TO VENEZUELA, I
WOULD SAY WE AS THE
UNITED STATES SHOULD PROMOTE OUR
VALUES AND DO THINGS LIKE
RECOGNIZING THE INTERIM
PRESIDENT.
WE HAVE TO KEEP IN MIND WHAT IS
THE BEST WAY WE CAN AFFECT THE
OUTCOME WE WANT?
>> Greg: SO YOU ARE SAYING
ASSASSINATION.
>> Marie: SOMETIMES THE
UNITED STATES HAS TRIED TO GET
CERTAIN OUTCOMES BY BEING TOO
INVOLVED IN OTHER COUNTRIES
INTERNAL AFFAIRS, BY SUPPORTING
OPPOSITION LEADERS OR
REVOLUTIONS.
WE HAVE TO KEEP IN MIND THAT WE
HAVE A LITTLE BIT OF A CHECKERED
HISTORY HERE.
THE OTHER THING I WOULD BRING UP
IS THE DIPLOMATS THAT ARE STILL
THERE.
PRESIDENT MADURO HAS ASKED THEM
TO LEAVE.
THE PRESENT WE ARE RECOGNIZING
NOW IS ASKING THEM TO STAY.
AS OF RIGHT NOW, THEY ARE
STAYING BUT THEY ARE IN THE
MIDDLE OF A VERY TENSE SECURITY
SITUATION.
THEY ARE SHORT OF BEING USED AS
PAWNS HERE ON THE GROUND BY BOTH
SIDES.
THAT CONCERNS ME.
IT WORRIES ME A LITTLE BIT.
>> Greg: DAN, I DON'T SEE BOTH
SIDES.
12 YEARS, THIS WAS A BEAUTIFUL
COUNTRY.
>> Dan: THE GDP OF VENEZUELA
WAS 334 BILLION.
IT'S BEEN WIPED OUT IN
94 BILLION.
SOCIALISM IS A PLAGUE AND A
STAIN ON HUMANKIND THAT HAS A
100% SUCCESS RATE OF FAILURE.
AND I'M TIRED OF THESE DEMOCRATS
SAYING DENMARK IS SOCIALIST.
IT'S NOT.
SOCIALISTS --
THOSE ARE CAPITALIST COUNTRIES.
STOP CONFLATING THE TWO.
YOU ARE CONFUSING PEOPLE.
SOCIALISM IS DEATH INSTRUCTION
AND I'M GLAD YOU MENTIONED THE
APOLOGISTS.
FASCISM HASN'T ESCAPED THIS.
SOCIALISM HAS BECAUSE THE PEOPLE
AND BERNIE SANDERS.
>> Greg: JESSE, WOULD YOU DO,
PRESIDENT WATERS?
A >> Jesse: SCARY THOUGHT.
IF I WAS A REPORTER ON
CAPITOL HILL, I WOULD GO TO AOC
AND SAY LOOK WHAT'S HAPPENING IN
VENEZUELA, CARE TO COMMENT?
OBVIOUSLY THIS IS A CIA
OPERATION.
YOU CAN ALLOW A FAILED STATE IN
SOUTH AMERICA WHERE THE CHINESE
AND THE RUSSIANS COME IN AND
TAKE OVER.
I MEAN, THIS COUNTRY IS AWASH IN
WEALTH, MINERAL WEALTH AND OIL
AND GOLD AND GOOD PEOPLE.
YOU CAN'T LET IT DESCEND INTO